all right so we're time couple or few
lessons together so I'm doing that same
thing okay when I move into him you'll
feel uh an increase in the
Y that might cause a flexion but as I
move into him I release that tension so
there's no flection okay so keep that in
mind the same if you push this harder
there's an increase in the
Y and I maintain positional integrity
and I let go of any added tension that
that arose from that if I go towards him
there's an increase in the yangong and I
have to again practice the releasing to
move there so you might feel a tension
just let it go till it goes away
here do the first
drill go tension then move to hand and
let go of
tension I only move like an inch or two
and I let go of
tension but I still keep the elbow
shoulder claw wi so I do the first Dr
Let It
Go move towards
him let go of any tension thats
okay
that's so my my drill is that you're
going to create an environment where the
likelihood is that you're going to
flex that is generated by tasking myself
with he's going to push and I'm going to
keep my hands Stu to get it and so it
when I feel that flexion I let go of it
always let go that's my only task let go
the flexion any flexion that
generates then I I'm going to increase
and as I increase I let go of the
tension any tension that
arises I
just then pic
tension any that
arises in in truth that that's the drill
tension arises like all this would be
the only training I would do
who
cool maybe hard to tell what the hell
that was so I here I will release I'll
amplify the problem release as I'm going
forward release release and I
just that's all our Dr okay let's try it
again I'm combine
the other drill so I'm
working on the tesak the inward spiral
and the outward
spiral inward
spiral outward
spiral makes the heart two of
them
okay I still have my elbow shoulder
fall I'm going to
increase the likelihood that you're
going to tend so the first one you're
going to do is disengage one
qu I still have to stay in that same
relaxed state
can't push can't do anything any
different even though I'm in this angle
okay that qua is going to come back and
I'm going to
do the inward spiral with the same
releasing no tension in my body okay I
come back qu comes back shoulder elbow
stays with it I start the other spiral
qu
moves quad comes forward CL comes back
and move him still there's nothing
here my hands will drop the in back
here during the increasing of the
pressur I don't respond to
that for
[Music]
okay let's try
it okay so right here Adam's
goinging it doesn't
matter stay
there turn
there's
no see then
it
exercise
see so show you the different
understanding you're understanding this
that you're going to
move his head this way okay my
understanding is your head's turn and
I'm going to move your whole body this
way and then here's
that okay so watch How I do
that see that okay your understanding is
going to require you to always be taller
hey it probably worked all this time
you're the tallest in the doj but it's
not the technique so
watch okay this way this way even if he
doesn't stay there he'll get there
okay now watch my
clock watch watch how much movement
there is and there
seem
okay now watch the B
drop okay try it again
have to change what we're
doing I'm taking out the last
one
okay you guys see that
at a certain
point you see how his head
is arcing around his Bas of support you
see
that so at a certain point his head gets
lower that creates the yin space for the
Honda fill you see right and I'm going
around his head
you have to resist the
temptation to go here can you see no
here you guys see that you feel that
okay second Point don't get in his
shoulder
anymore go his
heaviest same thing here don't come in
his head move his Center you see feel
the center then and it drops okay so
let's try that